NILE RODGERS: Hey, I'm
Nile Rodgers, and thanks
for watching Talks at Google.
ANANT SHUKLA: Joining us
today, with his Hitmaker,
please give a warm welcome
to Mr. Nile Rodgers.
[APPLAUSE]
NILE RODGERS: How you doing?
How you doing?
How are you?
ANANT SHUKLA: So Nile,
welcome to Google.
NILE RODGERS: Thank you.
ANANT SHUKLA: Today, we're
going talk a little bit
about your background, your
music, your FOLD festival,
obviously.
NILE RODGERS: That's triple
Grammy winner, by the way.
ANANT SHUKLA: Exactly.
Exactly.
NILE RODGERS: I was
like, Grammy winning?
Triple Grammy.
Dude, it took me all
those years and do it.
No, sorry, go ahead.
ANANT SHUKLA: We brought
the Hitmaker along as well,
your trusty sidekick.
So why don't you
just get us started,
tell us a little bit
about how you first
got involved in music.
And during your childhood,
how did that influence you?
NILE RODGERS: Well,
we're in a neighborhood
that's actually just a
few blocks away from where
I was born.
And back in the day when
dinosaurs walked the earth,
music was part of the
standardized American
curriculum.
So they taught music in school.
I learned how to read music in
school, and I just kept going.
It was one of the few things
that I actually liked doing.
And before I knew it, I was
doing it professionally.
I played in various
high school orchestras,
in junior high
school orchestras.
And my first professional
job was with "Sesame Street."
I was probably around 17,
18, something like that.
And then I went
from "Sesame Street"
to the Apollo
Theater in one year.
And about a year after I
worked at the Apollo Theater,
I wound up going on the road
with a group called New York
City.
And we were the opening act
for the Jackson 5 for a bit.
And a few years after that,
I wrote my first single,
and it was a hit.
But I didn't get a
Grammy, but it was a hit.
Sold millions of copies.
And then my second record
was a hit, and my third,
and my fourth, and my
fifth, and my sixth.
And what was really interesting,
it hit me the other day
that I didn't work with a star
until I worked with Diana Ross.
And that was the first
time I worked with a star,
and it was like a
super, super, superstar.
And by the time I
worked with Diana Ross,
I actually didn't even
have to work again.
I could have just quit
the music business
and lived off of royalties.
Ah, the good old days when we--
the time when we used to get
paid, you know?
I mean, I really could have.
Because at that
point, I had already
written "We Are Family,"
which was a huge copyright,
and "The Freak"
and "Good Times."
And then Sugarhill
Gang sampled that
and gave me "Rapper's Delight."
I think the suggested
retail price
for "Rapper's Delight" was $1.98
for one song, for a single.
Or no, it was $2.99,
so it was ridiculous.
After "Rapper's Delight,"
I honestly could have said,
OK, I'm hanging up my guns, and
I'm going to watch the world.
ANANT SHUKLA: Your family was
also always very supportive
of music.
You were surrounded, as
a child, by musicians.
Did they push you
one way or the other?
Or just organically, like you
said, one step after another,
and it just kept going?
NILE RODGERS: You're
really funny, man.
Did they push me?
No, my parents were
heroin addicts.
They were loving and wonderful,
but were not exactly motivated
or motivators, but
they were awfully cool.
My stepfather was maybe one of
the coolest guys I've ever met,
but they were full-time
heroin addicts.
And so I had to motivate myself.
The reason why I had
such cool jobs, I think,
is because I started
working at a young age.
I had a very powerful work
ethic that hasn't diminished
one bit to this very day.
So you know, I actually
think it was natural for me
to have a full-time
job at "Sesame
Street" at 19 years old.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And you also moved
between New York and LA.
The opportunities arose
naturally there as well.
NILE RODGERS: Yeah,
I was bi-coastal,
and it was mainly because
I wasn't a legal adult.
So I had to live with
some parental figure,
so I moved to California to
live with my grandparents
on different occasions.
But my childhood was so
weird, because I usually
was the only something
in the school.
So I was baptized Roman
Catholic, so I started out
at Catholic school.
And because of the neighborhood
that I was living in,
I would be the only
black person in my class.
That was the same in New
York as well as Los Angeles.
So when I got to Los
Angeles, my first trip,
I was seven years old.
I felt very uncomfortable.
I felt like I didn't belong.
But I found that there
was one place I really
did belong, movie theaters.
And Los Angeles
had lots of them.
And I played hooky
for 75 days straight.
I set the national truancy
record for parochial school
at seven years old,
and I was kicked out
of the parochial school system.
That's actually my
proudest-- forget
the triple Grammys,
75 days straight
without getting caught.
And you may wonder,
how did I do that.
Well, in Catholic school, they
give you money, an offering
to give in every day.
And I take that money,
and I would pay off a wino
and say, write a note.
Because I knew that a wino,
even a really inebriated one,
his handwriting looked a hell
of a lot better than mine.
And I would give that
to whatever authority
figure I'd run into.
Excuse my son Nile.
He has asthma and, he took
off the first half of the day
because he had a
really high fever.
But he feels great
now, so he would
like to go see all
of those movies
that you have playing
in your theater.
And I did that every single day.
And I really got
bold when I-- I know
I'm going way off topic here.
But I really got bold one day,
because I just wanted to see,
could I really get
away with this.
So I walked up to
police officers,
and I whipped out my note.
That note was like gold.
Whipped out the note.
And I said, I'm
suffering from asthma,
but, you know, the
attack went away.
And now I got a
few hours to kill,
and I want to go see this
movie, but I don't know
if I can get there in time.
And the cops said,
we'll drive you.
It was so cool.
So those were the
good old days in LA.
But then after they caught
me, they kicked me out,
and I came back to New York.
And I went to school
here for a while.
And it's so different,
because in those days,
we were really romantic.
Everything-- like, the next
day was going to be heaven.
And so coming back to
New York to go to school
was really weird, because in
LA, school was going to movies.
In New York, school
was dreadful.
But somehow I made really
great friends, did well,
and I learned to play music.
ANANT SHUKLA: That's what I was
going to ask you next though.
Where did the guitar, then,
fit in on this journey?
When did you realize the guitar
was the instrument for you?
NILE RODGERS: So it was
all about the culture.
So at the time, they were
teaching classical music
in school, which I
love, by the way.
And the last instrument that
I played classical music on
was the clarinet.
And the b-flat clarinet,
the written range
is the same as the guitar.
So I grew up during the hippie
anti-war years, you know,
that sort of thing.
The early '70s, late
'60s, that was my era.
I don't really know any
cool hippie anti-war
songs on the clarinet.
I can see Woody Guthrie with
the clarinet, do-do, do-do.
So it was definitely
not the instrument,
the anti-war instrument.
So I picked up the guitar.
And the fact that it
was the same written
range as the
clarinet was amazing,
because now I had
tons of books that
had been provided for me in
the wonderful school system.
And I had lots of
etudes to practice.
And guitar players are
notoriously bad music readers.
And that gave me a serious
one-up on almost all the studio
players here in New York City.
So I was playing on
records right away.
I was gigging instantly.
As soon as people had
found out that, hey,
we got that guy with the weird
hair, and he can read music.
Hire him to do your
television commercials.
I was making money.
So 16, 17 years old, I
was very self-sufficient.
ANANT SHUKLA: You were
gigging with the greats.
I read the story about
you and Jimi Hendrix.
What was that story?
Or were there other
idols and mentors
during that phase that--
NILE RODGERS: Yes.
So on 8th Street, between
6th and MacDougle,
Jimi Hendrix was
building his studio.
Matter of fact, that's where
I recorded "Random Access
Memories" with Daft Punk.
When he was building that
studio, it was-- prior to him
building it, it was-- a
nightclub called Generation.
And we used to jam at
Generation all the time.
And when Hendrix was in the
neighborhood doing the studio,
you would see him around,
jamming in different clubs.
So in the old days, we
didn't have Doppler radar.
And I remember,
one day, my band,
we were working
at the Bitter End.
And we had no-- we knew
that it was going to snow,
but we had no idea it
was going to snow snow.
It was so much snow
it was like a joke.
You'd try to open
the door, and it was
like the snow was that high.
So we went over to
this guy's loft.
And the loft was a loft
slash recording studio slash
macrobiotic restaurant slash
political headquarters slash
whatever, you know.
And we went over, and
we started jamming.
And Jimi walked in and
started jamming with us.
And we all had this
big, groovy circle
of everybody just doing a
freestyle jam like in the movie
"Spinal Tap," like, hey man,
when we do our freestyle.
So anyway, we were
just freestyle jamming,
and it was wonderful.
I believe that the
composition we improvised
was brilliant and genius.
I was on acid and so was
everybody else in the room,
so everybody else believed it
was brilliant and genius too.
And the thing that was funny
is we were just jamming,
and everybody went to the same
tonal centers, and we got it,
and it was a perfect jam.
And then, finally, as the
whole groove backed down,
right to complete tacit, we
hear this voice come out.
And it was Jimi, and he
went, uh, did anybody record
that man?
The recording engineer was
standing right next to me
with a bass.
It was like, well, I guess not.
So you know, that that's
how it was around here.
This is such an
awesome neighborhood.
It was such a great childhood.
And it really gave me the tools.
Like, I didn't know
that I'd wind up-- I
knew I'd probably be a composer,
maybe a conductor, an arranger.
But I didn't know that I'd be
a producer, which, basically,
is the same as the
director of a film.
It's your job, it's
your responsibility
to bring in the
finished product.
So you're the coach.
You're the psychologist.
You're everything, because
you hire the people,
you fire the people.
And typically, when I produce,
I really run the show.
A lot of times I do records,
the artist, who's the star,
they don't even know
the other people who
are playing on their record.
And that's because I come
from the old school of studio
musicians where we
would just show up,
and people wouldn't know me.
A contractor would bring me in.
And they would say, who's
that guy with the weird hair,
because I've always
had weird hair.
Who's that dude with the
green hair and the corn rows
and the thing coming out.
I don't know.
He's Nile, but he can read
music really well, so let's see.
So I still make
records, on some level,
like the old-school school way.
I think there's a certain
excitement and enthusiasm when
you don't know the music.
You're completely
unfamiliar, and you're
trying to make the
contractor, or the artist,
or whomever is responsible for
you being in that seat happy.
So I treat everybody like that.
I mean, if you're a big
star, that's it, usually.
I got a phone call today.
I just wrote a song
for a really big star.
The head of her record company
called me and said, Nile,
this shit's amazing.
This is so good.
This is great.
She's in town for
the next few days.
Maybe you guys can
finish the song.
But someone else,
another really big star,
wants to work on the record with
you, and she's in Australia.
What do we do?
I'm going, dude, you're
the record company.
What do we do?
I like this record so much.
If she doesn't do her part,
let's finish it by the weekend.
And I said, well, I'm fine.
I love the challenge of
waking up and knowing
that your situation
is impossible,
and somehow, at the end
of the day, going, man,
this sounds like a hit record.
ANANT SHUKLA: So you've
beaten addiction.
You've beaten cancer.
Did you ever think that--
NILE RODGERS: Beaten it?
Temporarily just--
ANANT SHUKLA: Knock
on-- hopefully, right?
Did you ever think you were
going to give up music and try
something else?
Are there other
passions that you were
trying to pursue on the side?
NILE RODGERS: Well, I
didn't give up music.
I can't do that,
I don't believe.
I think it's really in my DNA.
It's just who I am.
But I did realize I had some
sort of talent for writing.
I wrote my memoir,
which people love.
I've turned down
God knows how many
filmmakers who've wanted to do
the story, really famous ones.
And the only reason
why I did that is
because I've chosen to do
it as a Broadway show first.
So I've already
completed act one.
We read last week.
And my producer said it was the
best cold reading of a musical
he's ever heard in his life.
He says, Jesus Christ, most
people would end act one with
"We Are Family."
You start your show with it.
And he's like, what
else is coming?
And it was hit after
hit after hit after hit.
And he was like, phew.
So I just said, well,
that's the story arc.
The songs support the story arc.
And that's how I hear it.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
Well, one of your
latest projects,
you've moved into music
festivals now, right?
So the FOLD festival
now in its second year
here in Long Island,
debuting in London.
You're working with Kesha,
Joe Jonas, Bette Midler.
NILE RODGERS: Yeah,
Earth, Wind & Fire.
ANANT SHUKLA: KC and the--
NILE RODGERS: KC and the
Sun-- Village People.
ANANT SHUKLA: How did
you pick the lineup?
And how did FOLD come
to be what it is today?
NILE RODGERS: OK.
So the way that
FOLD originated was,
four years ago, I was in
Montreux, Switzerland,
and they wanted to
give me an award.
I was going, I don't understand.
Well, actually, what
we really want to do,
Nile, is we want to honor you.
I was going, wait a minute.
The last time I was
here and we honored
somebody, what happened?
I said that guy went to
a Rolling Stones concert.
Afterwards, he fell down
the steps, and he died.
No way.
Don't honor me.
That's what you do at the
end of a person's career.
I says, why don't
we honor the music?
And they said, well,
what do you mean?
I said, why don't we
honor the music that
makes you want to honor me?
He didn't quite get the concept,
but I called Mark Ronson,
Grace Jones, a bunch of people.
And I called a bunch
of friends, and we
put on an 11-hour
festival of dance music.
Like, we did a festival
within the jazz festival.
And it was so incredibly
successful, I'm
chasing that high again.
I don't know if I could
ever pull that off,
but it was just unbelievable.
And I think the thing that
makes FOLD really unique
is that you can tell that
we all love each other.
Like, when you go to a
concert, even though we're all
competitive-- you know,
you go out and go,
yeah, we smoked so-and-so.
Ha ha.
There's a great story.
Well, no, It's just too cool.
So I will not mention
artist A, but artist A
decided they wanted to be
the star and get top billing,
and Rick James was not the star.
And Rick James went
out and smoked.
And as he was going back
to his dressing room,
he went, your turn.
So we all have that thing.
But at my FOLD festival, because
everybody, we're all friends,
we're not trying to
smoke the other person.
We're actually trying
to lift each other up.
So it's become this thing
where the people feel the vibe.
The bands feel the vibe.
It's incredible.
Last year Pharrell said,
I've never had so much fun.
Janell Monet-- incredible.
Chaka Khan.
Keith Richards and-- Keith
Richards-- whoa-- Keith Urban
and I-- Keith Richards--
Keith Urban and I
turned it into Woodstock.
We just went off and started
jamming for 15 minutes.
So that's what I'm
trying to build on,
that old festival
feeling where--
ANANT SHUKLA: Because you went
to Woodstock as a teenager.
NILE RODGERS: Yeah,
boy, I was a kid.
ANANT SHUKLA: You performed
at Line Aid-- Live Aid, sorry.
Did those festivals
influence you in shaping FOLD
and how it is today?
NILE RODGERS: It was
a little different.
At Woodstock, I was a
kid, so I wasn't going
to be invited up on the stage.
That's for sure.
But at Live Aid, yeah,
Live Aid, I played.
It's actually a
great, funny story.
Oh man, how much
time do we have?
ANANT SHUKLA: You got time.
Don't worry.
NILE RODGERS: This is funny.
OK.
So Live Aid, here we are.
Live Aid, getting
ready to go on stage.
Right before we go on
stage, Lionel Ritchie
calls us all in a room.
And if you look at
the video of Live--
it's like every big star.
Like, Madonna, blah,
ah-- I mean, everybody.
Calls us all in a room.
And he says, you know, we
have a great sound engineer,
Bob Clearmountain, who happened
to be my normal sound engineer.
I'm with him every day.
Yeah, he is great, but he's Bob.
He says, well, we have Bob
Clearmountain mixing our sound.
So because of the way
that the stage is,
you have to stand-- you
would have a mic here,
a mic here, a mic here,
a mic here, and so on,
so on, so forth.
And it was a huge setting.
And Bob Clearmountain was
mixing the sound way out
in center field.
So Lionel tells all of
us, who are professionals
like himself-- we may not
have had as many hit records,
but we still do the same thing.
So he says, whatever you do,
don't take the microphone out
of the stand, because
Bob is queuing
from where you're standing.
He'll know he's on mic
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So you have to leave your mic
in the stand, and don't move.
So when it comes up to
your-- when it comes time
to do your vocal bit, just
stand right in place and go,
there comes a time-- whatever.
There's a choice we're making.
So we play the intro.
Paul Shaffer's the band leader.
[HUMMING MELODY]
Starts with Lionel.
Pop-- there comes a time
when we all-- ha ha.
Lionel.
There's a choice we're making.
We're saving our-- now,
the next person to come in
is Harry Belafonte.
So Harry's at his spot,
but Lionel's already
moved over here.
So he turns on the mic
there, no Harry Belafonte.
So nothing comes.
Harry Belafonte is singing.
And so Eric Clapton is
next to me and goes,
[SIMULATING ELECTRIC
GUITAR SOUNDS.
And I'm standing
here, just trying
to play the song diligently
and read the chart.
So everybody figures
I'm the new kid in town
even though it's 19-- what-- 85.
I've been making hit records
for seven years or something,
but oh, I didn't do big
rock and roll concerts.
So everybody figures, I'm so
excited, it must be me, right?
It can't be Eric.
So if you go on YouTube and
you look at "We Are The World,"
you'll see all these big
rock stars turn around,
and look at me, and go--
and I'm going-- of course,
I don't do that.
But I'm saying,
it's the superstar.
But that's the kind
of fun atmosphere
I like to have at my festival.
Music, to me, is a
living, breathing thing.
It's not perfect every night.
We're still an old-school band.
We don't have secret
backing tracks running
and stuff like that.
And I know, nowadays, most-- oh.
ANANT SHUKLA: Don't worry.
NILE RODGERS: See, I told
you things are imperfect.
Yes.
But those obstacles and
those variables, that's
part of performing.
That's the cool thing.
It's the energy that goes into
it, the love, the precision.
We can play.
It's pretty obvious
we know how to play.
So every time that we make a
mistake, to us, it's funny.
And it's just part
of live performing.
So I've tried to bring that
kind of vibe to the festivals.
And you'll find that-- or
at least what I've observed
is that you have less violence.
It's like magic.
You have fewer problems.
People just seem to
become part of your thing.
We invite people on the stage.
When we play, we have total
strangers come up on stage.
And that's why these incidents
that have just happened lately
really break my
heart, that you could
have such incredible violence
at music establishments.
The girl-- I'm sorry,
I don't know her name,
the artist who was killed.
And according to what
they said on the news,
she was reaching out to
a fan with open arms,
and he just shoots her.
And then, of course,
the horrible-- and this
was also in the same
city, at the club Pulse,
where a guy just goes down
and guns down 50 people.
In my heart, music has
always been this safe thing.
I was the one black kid in
this class who didn't fit.
I was the one so and so.
But man, put me on
the clarinet, I fit.
I might be sitting second
chair, but I still fit.
I'd fit in the orchestra.
I would fit with
the other musicians.
I try and run my
sessions the same way.
I try and make everybody
feel like we're all the same.
It's just--
ANANT SHUKLA: You started We
Are Family, the foundation,
after 9/11 as well,
in the aftermath.
NILE RODGERS: Boy,
that was a segue.
Yeah.
ANANT SHUKLA: That
was similar, right,
that you were trying to
bring happiness to the world
and spread that mission,
right, through music?
NILE RODGERS: Yeah.
Well, what happened
exactly was--
so my charity is called the We
Are Family Foundation, based
after a song I wrote.
Three of my friends
were in the first plane
that was crashed into the
North Tower on September 11.
And it was just
mind boggling, one,
that anyone could do
something so horrific.
But the fact that
I had three people
that I knew on one airplane,
the first airplane, just
seemed-- what are
the odds of that?
And it just happened
that I had been in a film
with Nelson Mandela, and
somebody from South Africa
was watching that film.
So they're in a
different time zone.
So even though this
event was playing out
early in the morning here,
it was later in the afternoon
there.
And they called me up.
And they said, Nile, you
should redo your song
"We Are Family" to help
usher in a sense of healing.
As a composer, that
sounded so weird to me.
I was like, no, "We Are Family,"
that's just the Sledges song.
It was about their family.
And they said, no, but
you don't understand
that "We Are Family" is played
at bar mitzvahs, and weddings,
and this, and all these
celebratory events.
And I reluctantly
went along with it,
because it just didn't make
sense to me artistically.
Well, now-- what are we now?
12 years later,
11 years later, we
have a wonderful organization
that does incredible work
all around the world.
We've affected, I would have
to say, if not billions,
certainly more than
a billion people.
And it's probably
one of the best
parts of my life, my charity.
Jess is over there.
She first came to our charity
as a volunteer, I think.
She was a-- oh no,
you were a mentor.
Volunteer.
Now she's like the boss.
Yes, Jess.
What do I do today?
Having the We Are
Family Foundation
has changed my life, the way
that we interact with kids
all over the world.
And our programs that we've
generated are unbelievable.
We have TEDxTeen,
which has become huge.
We've built schools in, I would
say, at least 17, if not 18,
countries.
We've done a lot.
We've impacted
quite a few people.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
So we're going to open it up
to audience Q&A as well if you
guys want to start queuing.
NILE RODGERS: Yea, audience Q&A.
ANANT SHUKLA: But let's now
talk about The Hitmaker sitting
right next to you.
NILE RODGERS: Wait a minute.
One things that's
really awesome is
that, right before we started,
a gentleman walked up to me
and said, wow, I heard--
yeah, it was so cool
that you worked with Daft Punk.
And this is a true story.
You can show yourself
if you're brave enough.
He walked up to and he says, did
they let you see their faces?
So as I was getting mic'd,
I said to him, dude,
you know that was the dumbest
question in the world.
Like, you think they're
sitting around their studio, oh
man, it's 150 degrees inside.
We can be really creative now.
Phew.
Anyway, how you doing?
AUDIENCE: Hey, how you doing?
My name is Dominique.
Thanks so much for
being here, and thank
you so much for creating some
of my favorite music-- you know,
"We Are Family," "Le Freak,"
and Daft Punk-- this music
that transports me
to a different time
and a different place.
So thank you.
NILE RODGERS: Oh,
you're welcome.
AUDIENCE: My question
for you is, how do you,
as a producer, engender
creativity in the people
that you work with.
How do you balance
directing them and just
getting the creativity
to come out of them?
What's your approach?
NILE RODGERS: It's
different based
on the artist's personality.
But the one thing
that I try and do
is make you understand that
I absolutely have your best
interests at heart, that
I'm very aware of the fact
that, after we
finish the record,
it's going to say Daft Punk,
produced by Nile Rodgers.
Your name is going
to be really big,
and my name is going
to be really small.
So it's all about the
artist, and I'm just
trying to help them visualize
and bring to fruition whatever
artistic ideas they may have.
And sometimes, if I'm
lucky, we actually
make them better than what
they thought they could do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NILE RODGERS: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Nile.
Thank you so much for making
all this amazing music.
I have tremendous
respect for your work.
My question is actually similar
to what our colleague said.
What was the most
challenging session
that you've ever been on?
And how did you make the record
happen at the end of the day?
Also, Jerry says hi.
NILE RODGERS: Oh, cool.
My Jerry?
AUDIENCE: Jerry Barnes.
NILE RODGERS: Oh, cool, yeah.
Oh, great.
That's my bass player.
ANANT SHUKLA: And maybe
you can tell us, as well,
how the song evolved in
a challenging session.
NILE RODGERS: I'm trying to
think, what do I consider hard?
Oh, OK.
The hardest session, when I
think in terms of what it was
and what it morphed
into, would probably
be "Let's Dance" by David Bowie.
And it wasn't because
it was hard technically.
It was a spiritual and artistic
communications problem that I
thought existed, but it didn't.
It's probably easier to
show you than to explain
some abstract stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
So when we were doing
the album "Let's Dance,"
before David and I had
written one note of music--
[STRUMMING GUITAR]-- we had gone
all around New York City going
to different museums and
different places that had huge
repositories of records, and
rock and roll iconography,
and things like that.
We didn't write any music.
We just wanted to look at stuff.
So after about a week or two
of looking and listening,
David came to my apartment.
And he says-- he had
something behind his back.
And he wend, Nile,
darling, I want my record
to sound like this.
And he basically
wanted the record
to sound like this picture.
And the picture
was Little Richard
in a red suit-- I
happened to wear red pants
today-- red suit.
His coif was red, and he was
getting into a red Cadillac
convertible.
But I knew that that photo
didn't represent the past,
even though you can understand--
you could tell what year it was
by the model of the Cadillac.
What that photo showed,
it looked like something
from the future.
So he was trying to
say that he wanted
to make a record that would
sound like we just made it
today no matter
what year it was.
That's what it meant.
That's what that
red picture meant.
And I knew that's what he meant.
So he walked into my
bedroom about a week later.
And he says, Nile, darling--
for some reason, Nile,
the word "Nile"
always was followed
with the word "darling."
He went, Nile, darling, I
just wrote this last night,
and I think this could be a hit.
It goes something like this.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
And I went, uh,
wow, that's weird.
Because we had just walked
around for two weeks,
and we had listened to all
this really cool music.
Everything we listened to was
cutting edge and incredible.
And to me, this sounded like
a folk song-- not a bad one,
but just, you know, like na-na.
And he was singing, let's
dance, da-da, da-da, da-da.
So I immediately thought that
he was pulling a trick on me.
I thought he was trying
to see if I was just
some sycophantish,
wacky dude who
wanted a paycheck or something.
So I called one of
his best friends.
And I said, is David
the kind of person
who would try and test me and
make me feel like an idiot?
And he said, no.
I said, well, he
walked into my room
today and told me that he
thinks this song is a hit.
And he said, Nile,
I promise you,
if David said he
thinks it's a hit,
he really believes it's a hit.
And I went, whoa.
So I said to him, in a moment
of-- I don't know what it was.
Maybe it was a
moment of brilliance,
or maybe I was trying
to keep my job.
I don't know what it was.
But I just, said, hey David,
can I do an arrangement?
And he went, sure.
I was like, whoa, awesome.
Now we were in Switzerland.
And the band Queen
owned a recording studio
in Switzerland, in
Montreux, Switzerland,
called Mountain Studios.
So I wrote out some charts, and
we hired some local jazz guys.
And instead of going
[PLAYING GUITAR],
I changed my guitar part
to [PLAYING GUITAR],
which sounded sort of cool.
But it still sounded a little
folky, because on the guitar,
on those frets,
you get harmonics.
So all I did was move it from
[PLAYING GUITAR] just up a half
step to [PLAYING GUITAR].
And all of a sudden, I was
like, oh, shit-- oh, Google.
All of a sudden, it went from
being live to sort of dead.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
And I was going,
man, this is cool.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
Oh, what I hadn't told
you was that David and I
had had countless
conversations about jazz,
and about jazz artists, and all
the jazz people that he liked.
So I knew that I could
get away with, instead
of going [PLAYING GUITAR], I
inverted the whole thing up
an octave.
I went [PLAYING GUITAR].
And then I put in a B
flat minor 13 chord,
which I knew he would love,
because he likes jazz.
He would just think
that was cool.
So I went [PLAYING GUITAR]
And he was like,
wow, that's my song?
I went, yeah, now
check this out.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
So then I just started
jamming and started
going [PLAYING GUITAR]
[APPLAUSE]
And so after, I
said, well, I think
these should be
the chord changes.
Let's make this the progression.
He said, ah, I love it.
And I said, cool.
We ran to the studio.
I had all the
charts written out.
So that was just the
audition session just
to see if he would say,
I hate it or love it.
Then I gave all the music
to the band, to the players.
We didn't know any of the guys.
They were just
local studio guys.
And it was very much like
"Let's Dance" that you know.
And I remember asking
him, David, do you
think I made this too funky?
And he said the coolest thing
I have ever heard in my life.
I cherish these words.
I cherish this artist.
He's wonderful.
He looked at me and went, Nile,
darling, is there such a thing?
I was like, you are the man.
I get it.
If we can ever reach that
point of being too funky,
we go to Nirvana or something.
It was like, is
there such a thing?
Can you make a song too funky?
Could you ever achieve that?
So I obviously didn't
make it too funky.
The arrangement that
I wrote out is exactly
the arrangement we wound up
playing back in New York.
Didn't change anything.
And that's the
record we put out.
Someone, earlier, asked me if
there's ever any pressure on me
to put out the outtakes
of "Let's Dance."
I said, there is no
outtakes of "Let's Dance."
We played it.
We got it right.
That's "Let's Dance."
There is no other version.
That's the only one that exists.
AUDIENCE: So I
have two questions.
The first one-- you talk
a bit about arrangement.
I'm always a believer
in, Da Vinci's art
is only ever abandoned,
never finished.
So I wanted to ask you,
firstly, how you know when
you've finished an arrangement.
And secondly, you take a
very progressive approach
to collaborating and working
with other artists, obviously,
anyone from Biggie to
your recent collaboration
with the Martinez brothers.
I'm kind of curious
whether you've
thought about alternative
licensing routes
that you might take such that
once you are no longer with us,
people continue to make Nile
Rodgers music with your samples
and your estate
enables that to happen.
NILE RODGERS: You are so cool.
Because that's-- I'm
not waiting to die.
I'm already--
that's what I think
the world is going towards.
That's what I think the music
business is going to become.
The old model of composition
will still remain somewhat,
but I think that the newer
model, especially when I
work with a lot of
artists-- I go in there,
and they say hey, Nile,
listen to this track.
And I listen, and I go, um,
I'm playing guitar on there.
I just met you.
Oh yeah, right.
Well, we pulled that
from the outtake.
We found one of your tapes,
and it had this thing on there.
So yeah, I think that we're in
a sort of cut and paste world
where we can take an
idea from someplace,
and we can actually, digitally,
take the full bandwidth sample.
So I recently did a thing
for the film "Trolls."
And I recreated
something exactly,
not because they
couldn't do it, but just
so I wanted to give them
the advantage of being
able to do a whole full
bandwidth representation
of the music if they wanted to.
If they didn't want
to, you could just
go back and get the sample.
And speaking of Biggie, it's
the song we did with Biggie.
And you can go get that
sample and just do that.
But the fact that it
came up in that film,
and I just did this two
weeks ago, and the fact
that you brought it up today--
although you were thinking I
was thinking like
that, after I die--
it's the way that
the world is going.
That's composition.
That's what's going to happen.
We're going to
actually not only take
the original motifs, but
even the original recordings.
And we'll redesign them,
and reorchestrate them,
and rework work.
They'll become very malleable.
I just finished a record with
Elton John and Janelle Monae
that I composed in 4/4.
The final version
of it is in 6/8,
and they never had
to re-sing it again.
I painstakingly took two
weeks to make this thing move
note by note by note, and
it sounds letter-perfect.
And when you hear
the next Chic album,
if you happen to
listen to it, listen
to the song that's
in 6/8 and remember
that I cut that in 4/4.
AUDIENCE: It is such
an honor to meet you.
My name is Sanjay.
I used to be a session
pianist in Hollywood,
and I was very poor,
and I got tired.
And I eventually came here.
NILE RODGERS: Wow,
a real step up.
AUDIENCE: And that's my point.
I wasn't valued as a musician.
I was not-- all my friends
who were session players
couldn't find work, because
music is being produced
by a single producer, a
DJ, on Pro Tools or Ableton
on their laptop at home.
And so there's this idea
in Hollywood right now,
and the like
instrumentalists feel
like they're no longer
important and they don't
have a place in music anymore.
I was curious-- I think there
is for certain artists, right?
If you're going to tour
with Beyonce, great.
But that's not even
1% of artists, right?
So it's just very difficult,
devoting your whole life
to getting really, really good
at violin, to then never get
sessions or never get work.
I was just curious
what your thoughts are
on this digital music
ecosystem that's
being built out and
distributed and the importance
of live recordings
and how you feel
about what's going on from
the recording standpoint.
NILE RODGERS: So I understand
where you're coming from,
because that is real.
That's absolutely real.
But I think that, somehow,
the world writes itself,
and we'll go to a new
reality, sort of like what
the gentleman just mentioned.
We'll go to a new reality
where-- first of all, musicians
have traditionally
always been poor, bro.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I know.
I know.
NILE RODGERS: It's
only a handful of lucky
few that-- when you decide to
become a musician, you say,
I have now committed
myself to being poor.
So if you go into
music thinking that,
I'm going to make a fortune,
that's the wrong motivation.
That's just wacky.
It makes no sense.
But if you're lucky enough
to make a living at it,
and you can gig, and
you can do a church,
or you can work with Beyonce,
or whatever, that's amazing.
But I think that
music is so vital
that as many platforms
that exist now, all of them
suck up music.
It's almost like a black hole.
There's a need for more, and
more, and more, and more music
for some reason.
Actually, another song never
actually has to be composed
and we'd have plenty of music.
But that's just how it is.
People want something
new or something
that appears to be new.
So there's going to be a way
that great violinists will
have something to offer.
I believe, learn
your instruments.
Learn them well.
And if anything, you wind
up just having a good time.
There's nothing wrong
with having a good time.
I know you're at
Google and everybody
wants to be gazillionaires
and all that,
but it's also fun to have fun.
This was going to
be a hobby, sort of,
but it was a hobby that I
turned into a profession.
I actually like doing it.
I have more fun
playing music free
than I do the music
I get paid for.
Because the music
that I get paid for,
there has to be a result,
whereas when I'm just home
jamming, I'm having a blast.
No one's criticizing
me, and I don't
have to turn it in by Friday.
I can tell LA Reid, yo
man, she didn't show up.
ANANT SHUKLA: In the
interest of time,
we're going to do a few
quickfire questions.
NILE RODGERS: OK.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: For how long
you've been in the business
and worked with so many
different artists, and someone
like David Bowie, where
you worked with him twice
at different points
in his career--
NILE RODGERS: Four times.
AUDIENCE: Four times?
NILE RODGERS: Yeah.
Why'd you only think twice?
AUDIENCE: I thought
I said twice.
NILE RODGERS: No, I said,
why did you only think twice.
AUDIENCE: Oh, because
I thought it was "Let's
Dance" and "Black
Tie White Noise."
NILE RODGERS: Those are albums.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
NILE RODGERS: But then I
did "Dancing In The Street"
for Live Aid, him
with Mick Jagger.
And then I did a film for
Bakshi called "Cool World."
AUDIENCE: Oh, then
that was my mistake.
I apologize.
NILE RODGERS: That's OK.
AUDIENCE: As a
Bowie fan, I should
be embarrassed right now.
NILE RODGERS: It's not that
I really-- I'm like-- no.
AUDIENCE: I apologize.
NILE RODGERS: No, no, it's cool.
AUDIENCE: Anywho, my
question being that,
working with an artist
over this amount of time
and so many artists to now,
how has the technology changed
your approach as a producer?
And how do you find
it different in how
to communicate with
artists, such as,
is there a different
expectation of you as a producer
as there was 10 years
ago, 20 years ago?
And how does that
affect how you work?
NILE RODGERS: So
it's interesting,
the final outcome
expectation is the same.
They want a hit.
I got that part.
But because of the
technology-- like,
I just did a record
with Laura Mvula.
And she could see
me on the computer
while I was playing it.
And I could do this inversion,
and do that, and change it.
So it felt like she
was in the room.
As a matter of fact, we
just had-- at our last
We Are Family event, we
had-- a robot version of one
of our spiritual leaders, if you
will, walking around the room,
interacting with the kids.
So we now can have a physical
presence in the studio
even though I'm on a
different continent.
So I feel very
comfortable working
while the person is looking
over my shoulder on Skype.
Or if there's a robot in
the room looking down at me
and saying, hey Nile, what
if you played it there,
it feels very natural to me.
And I think that over
the next few years,
it's going to feel
even more organic.
That sense of a few milliseconds
away will just feel normal.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: I was more so
with about the technology
as far as recording
and things like that,
and how the artists
maybe view what
your position as a producer is.
NILE RODGERS: Well,
I think the artists
look at it in a similar way.
You gotta remember, artists
are not just the same.
I mean, there's a big difference
between Bowie and Madonna,
or the B-52s.
We're all different people,
and we all see the world
through our own lens.
But it feels-- to me,
it feels the same.
I just finished working
with people that
are 18 years old, 19 years old.
And it didn't feel any
different than working
with Lady Gaga or anyone else.
It was the same.
I just become smarter
about more gear.
There's just more gear.
Of course, I just
want gear anyway.
It's like clothes.
You just want more clothes.
You want more gear.
Just give me stuff
to fool-- like,
what does this
button do, you know?
The thing is that, with all
the technology that we build,
what are we trying to do?
All we're trying to do
is emulate the world
that we've come from.
Everything that
we build, we make
it to simulate the thing
that was in the room.
And that was the
thing that we were
trying to get around,
because it didn't
work as well as it should.
So it's a funny
paradox, right, where
we're making gear that's
sort of old-fashioned,
this really high-tech gear
to sound old-fashioned.
And it was the
old-fashioned stuff
that we had to figure
out, shit, what
do we do to make
this thing do that?
Because it, in and of
itself, can only do this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, that
explains it a bit better.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, it's a true
honor to see you here.
I'm a big fan, especially of
your work with Duran Duran.
I'm a huge fan of Duran Duran--
NILE RODGERS: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: --so I love that
you keep working with them.
I wanted to ask
about your guitar.
You've talked, in your
blog, about how you almost
lost it on a train.
You had to run, and
go to the police,
and go to the dispatch
and everything.
You finally found it.
And you're trying
to make a replica.
Is that correct?
NILE RODGERS: Done.
AUDIENCE: So what makes
the Hitmaker so special?
How did you guys come together?
NILE RODGERS: OK.
So what makes this
one special to me
is because I traded a really
big jazz guitar for it
and got $300 back and this.
It was like, whoa,
are you kidding me?
I get $300 too?
I didn't know anything
about solid body guitars
when I bought this.
I was a jazz guy
and a classical guy.
So I didn't know that
this would have been
considered a factory second.
In today's world, they
would've have passed this.
This wouldn't have
passed the inspection.
But in the year that
it was built, in 1959,
Leo Fender, the guy who
invented this company,
was so cheap that if he saw
a screw on the floor-- this
is a true story--
if he saw a screw,
he would pick up that
screw and look around
for something in the
room to put the screw in.
That's how cheap he was.
So there was no way he
was letting this imperfect
guitar not be sold.
So I bought it at
some cheap little pawn
shop in Miami Beach.
And it was-- it doesn't
meet factory specs
or anything like that.
And it has what they
call a hard tail.
That's because it's so thin that
you couldn't put a whammy bar
mechanism inside of it, so
you just put the strings
through the body.
So my guitar is lighter than
any Strat you've ever played.
It weighs nothing.
It was bought--
the wood that they
used to make it was
not grown at sea level.
Fender thought he
was getting a deal.
So he bought the wood.
And it wasn't going to be
the price as delivered.
It was the price, but
they had to go pick it up.
And when they got to the farm
where the wood was growing,
it was up on a mountain.
So when they got the wood
back from the factory,
it was dry enough to use right
away, whereas normally, they
would have the wood sit around
for, I don't know how long.
But they used it right away.
So this guitar was made.
And then they probably tried to
stretch the allotment of wood.
So everything that went
into making this thing wrong
makes it so right that,
when I got it, to me,
this is what a Fender
Strat sounded like.
So I then started playing
everything with this,
because it sounded unique to me.
And I thought all Fender Strats
sounded like this until I
went and bought my next one.
Oh man, it was like--
nothing sounds like this.
So yes, we have recreated it.
It took us almost 20 years.
We had to really take it apart.
We had to consider the density
of the wood, the moisture
content, the electronics,
which are totally just
regular Fender, nothing fancy.
The only thing that
seems like it's fancy
are these Gibson speed knobs.
Because back in the
day there were songs
that we used to play
like [PLAYING GUITAR]
And there was no dirt in my pot.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
Now we use a peddle to do it.
But it was cooler to be
in a nice, smoky club
and just go [PLAYING GUITAR]
[LAUGHTER]
So that's why they're on there.
And this I put on because I
just thought it looked cool.
No reason other than that.
It doesn't help with the
shielding or anything,
it just looked cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
ANANT SHUKLA: So can we
take both of your questions
together, just because
we have to run out?
NILE RODGERS: We're out of time?
Ooh, so sorry.
AUDIENCE: We'll speak
at the same time,
or you can combine these
question into one answer.
Like many Googlers here,
I'm involved in music.
And I think I understand
pretty well how
to make notes work together.
I'm a nerdy person.
I understand notes pretty well.
What I don't get
at all is how you
know when a song's going
to be a hit, how you take
an idea of a song and think,
wait, somewhere in there,
that's the hit sound
people are going
to like all over the world.
How do you do that?
And--
AUDIENCE: And my question is,
throughout your career, all
the music that you've
heard, what bleeds in
and what bleeds out of
you to make your sound?
NILE RODGERS: Wow, I don't--
I think I understand that.
The first one I
totally understand.
And the answer to
that is, I don't know.
You play the music.
You compose the music.
You perform it.
And if it makes you
really feel good,
then you hope that it makes
other people feel good too.
I don't know it.
I think the only two or
three times in my life--
and I've had hundreds--
hundreds, and hundreds,
and hundreds-- of
singles-- the only time
that I knew for a fact a song
was a hit was "We Are Family."
I knew it was a hit,
absolutely knew it,
because the guitar
part was smokin'.
"Le Freak," maybe because
the guitar part was smokin'.
And what other song?
Diana Ross.
I knew "I'm Coming
Out" was a hit
even though we put out
"Upside Down" first.
And in both cases
with Diana Ross,
putting "Upside
Down" out first, we
did that because we knew that
"I'm Coming Out" was a smash.
So we wanted to get that
one hit under our belt
and then come with
the smash after that.
Same thing with "We Are Family."
We knew that "We Are
Family" was so good that we
had another record on there
that was a smash called
"He's The Greatest Dancer."
People don't realize, "He's The
Greatest Dancer" was a platinum
single out of the box.
But "We Are Family" was so big
that people forget that "He's
The Greatest
Dancer"-- they forget
that I even did that song,
or that it even exists.
But it was actually
a monster hit.
And what I believe
you were saying,
the stuff that emanates from
the inside to the outside,
it's a very esoteric
question, bro.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
All the music that you've
heard in your life,
what have you clung to?
What have you grasped like, this
is the sound that I make in?
NILE RODGERS: OK.
So the music that I've heard,
all the music that I've
heard in my life, I love
bebop and modern jazz
the best, maybe fusion
jazz, just because
of the technical
proficiency, but so is bebop.
But I love classical music.
I grew up on classical music.
So that's what I practice.
That's what I practice when
I'm at home and I'm playing.
When I want to just
make myself feel good,
I'll play a
Thelonious Monk tune.
The other day, one of my
keyboard players and I,
we transcribed Eric Dolphy,
a song called "17 West,"
because we couldn't
find the chart for it.
And then after we transcribed
it, we looked it up on Google.
And there it was, "17 West."
It was like, oh, oops.
We went through
all that trouble,
and there it was, right there.
Yeah, so that's what it is.
As Al Jarreau says,
I'm a jazzer at heart.
And that probably has a lot
of influence on my pop music,
because I want things to be
harmonically interesting.
I am not a three-chord
rock guy, but boy, I sure
appreciate "Wild Thing."
I think that's amazing.
I'm a two-chord disco guy.
Our biggest hits
were two chords.
But it was just the way
that we invert them,
and the way that we play them,
and the way that we interpret
those two chords by building
smooth voice leading,
melodic passages by going
from one chord to the next.
It's not like you just
go, ah, freak out.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
That's the basic, but
I play [PLAYING GUITAR]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
the jazz is there too.
The jazz chords, the minor
seven chords are there,
the 11th chord in
"We Are Family."
All those jazz chords
give the songs interest.
NILE RODGERS: Right.
So a song like "We Are Family,"
which is basically just
[PLAYING GUITAR].
Right, the 11 chord?
But that ain't-- the guitar
part is [PLAYING GUITAR]
[APPLAUSE]
See, that's fun to play.
That is a hell of a lot
more fun to play than just,
[PLAYING GUITAR], we are family.
I got all my sisters.
That's not fun.
But [PLAYING GUITAR] that's fun.
[APPLAUSE]
ANANT SHUKLA: All right.
NILE RODGERS: Thank you.
ANANT SHUKLA: Unfortunately,
we're of time.
But let's give--
everybody, let's give him
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
NILE RODGERS: Thank you, guys.
Thanks a lot.
ANANT SHUKLA: Thank you, Nile.
NILE RODGERS: Thank you, bro.